make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and today we are back with
another what if video but this
one is going to be a little bit
different as we're going to step out of
the realm of comic books and into a
cartoon series
specifically into nickelodeon's avatar
the last airbender and we'll try to
answer the question
of what would happen if azula became the
avatar
now here's the thing my fiancee mariah
is a massive
avatar fan right she's an it's like to
give a guy's perspective of how huge of
an avatar fan she is
she had probably watched through the
series in the time that we've we've been
here in ohio she probably watched
through
the avatar series on amazon maybe like
six times
and then it went on netflix and then she
turned right back around and watched it
on netflix and i was like why are you
watching it on netflix like you already
know what happens in the show and she's
like because it's on netflix now and i
was like okay
that's kind of interesting uh also fair
warning i do kind of like to troll you
guys a little bit
so uh i'm probably gonna mess with you
guys over the course of this video
but just to set the stage here we know
that aang the subject of avatar the last
airbender was frozen in ice at the age
of 12 and remained there for a hundred
years before he was discovered and
thought out and of course
aang belonged to the air nomads and he
became the avatar upon the death of
avatar roku who was a member of the fire
nation and was so
important that he had a streaming device
named after him now this is relevant to
our story because the avatar cycles
through the four nations each time he
or she is reincarnated and so after roku
died the avatar passed from the fire
nation although i like to mess with
mariah and call it the fire kingdom it
gets her all kinds of upset ah but it
passed from the fire nation to the air
nomads and upon eng's death
the avatar then passed the kora of the
water tribe and the reason i mention all
this is that if azula is to become the
avatar then we need to establish the
succession of avatars through the air
nomads
water tribe and earth kingdom so that it
can finally return to azula in the fire
nation so avatar roku died in 12 bg
or 12 years before the air nomad
genocide i feel like it makes more sense
to just say that right 12 years before
the genocide and it's feel like it's a
good reference point at which point aang
became the avatar now aang is frozen in
year zero
and unthawed and 99 years after the
genocide but i think that since we want
to have the avatar
cycle through the air nomads the easiest
way for that is for eng to die
instead of interostasis within the
iceberg that would leave about 85 years
until azula's birth which would be
plenty of time
for the water tribe and earth kingdom to
each host the avatar
this would drastically change the events
prior to azula's birth because the
avatar would no longer be off the table
but a real threat to the fire lords
first sozen the instigator of the air
nomad genocide and later his son azalan
or
zulon whatever you want to call it uh
who would in turn have to deal with it
now you would still have the fire lords
attempting to take over the world during
the 100 years war but their strategy
would have to change to account for the
avatars and i think the most likely
scenario
is that the fire lords see the new
avatars as potential
weapons and so upon aang's death they
would turn their attention to the water
tribes hoping to find the new avatar and
eventually end up kidnapping whoever it
is
i think it also makes sense that the
fire lords would try and kidnap a master
bender from each nation to train the
avatar
so they'd probably have to leave one of
the airbenders alive during genocide and
then abduct a waterbender and an
earthbender but what ends up happening
is that try as they might they don't
seem to be able to corrupt the new
avatar into joining their cause
and so they kill the avatar and repeat
the process with the next one born into
the earth kingdom but have the same
problem this time as well
and so they figure that once one of
their own becomes the avatar
they won't encounter the problem of
being unable to influence their loyalty
and so they kill the avatar from the
earth kingdom
and the new avatar azula is born in the
fire nation to prince
ozai now one of the things we're kind of
doing here we're just sort of saying
it's a zula right i mean i imagine
people might respond and say well what
makes you think it would be a zulu i
don't know it's a cartoon who cares
about logic so
at this point there are basically two
ways this can go and the first is that
azula grows up to be evil with all the
powers of an avatar
and therefore becomes a nearly
unbeatable entity that propels the fire
nation
to world domination we're not going to
do that q like 90
of people turning off the video
instead knowing what we know about the
nature of the avatar
i don't think that's the most likely
scenario in fact i don't even think it's
really possible
and the reason for that is rava the
spirit of light which inhabits every
avatar since the spirit converged
with avatar 1 thousands of years ago
before the events of avatar the last
airbender so while one might be inclined
to assume
that because azula is crazy and evil
that she would become the first evil
avatar
i just don't think the spirit of rava's
influence would allow that to happen now
we're also taking some liberties here
right like there have been avatars who
were dicks right like it's just kind of
weird it was or they were terrible but i
would like to believe that when rava
takes over a host body that there's at
least
some kind of influence you know like
something that helps them to become a
good guy
but regardless what's going to happen is
azula is going to embrace the role of
the avatar as a force for peace
light and balance and of course this
will greatly alter the timeline going
forward and so what i see happening here
is that azula would undergo the usual
training from the water air and earth
vendors that the fire nation has
captured but also communicating with the
past avatars who inform her of the fire
lord's true nature
and employing her to use her powers to
stop his quest for world domination now
needing to keep her true intentions
hidden however she behaves as if she's
fully on board with her father ozai's
plan
to take over the world and so outwardly
she behaves much like we would see her
behave in the last airbender but this
is merely a front orchestrated to evade
suspicion but azula
does have one confidant in the fire
nation her uncle iro
who takes on the mentor role of azula in
much the same way he did to zuko in the
series
this would have a pretty big impact on
zuko's development as
he is still not going to be favored by
his father who sees azula as the key to
winning world domination
and this time he likely won't garner as
much attention from iro because ira will
be busy working with the order
of the white lotus to further the
avatar's mission so
this would most likely result in zuko
becoming jealous and embittered and
harboring great feelings of resentment
towards his sister and he would still
have
the unending desire to win the affection
of his father as he did in the series
and so the time would eventually come
when azula would have to fulfill her
destiny as the avatar
and rid the world of the threat
presented by her father which threatens
to throw off the balance between the
four natural elements
and much like we saw during the last
airbender the most logical time for this
to occur is on the day of the black sun
when the firebenders were unable to bend
fire due to the solar eclipse
as it turns out iro has been working
with the white lotus to orchestrate an
attack on the fire nation
along with members of the water tribe
and earth kingdoms and so predictably
the invasion
goes really well because the fire nation
is extremely vulnerable and unable to
amount much of a resistance
now firelord ozai however escapes after
being tipped off by zuko who's
eavesdropped on conversations between
azula and iro and relayed them to his
father to win his favor now while the
fire nation capital falls the threat of
ozai and zuko remains and the two of
them
return after their powers have been
restored following the day of the black
sun
to challenge azula and retake the throne
of the fire nation
and so azula's allies from the earth
kingdom and water tribe offer assistance
but being the avatar
has done nothing to diminish her
confidence and hubris and so she
declines their health
and battles her father and brother two
on one and so ozai and zuko are both
advanced firebenders but ultimately end
up being overwhelmed by the avatar after
a pretty epic battle
and whereas aang declined to kill ozai
instead opting to remove his bending
powers through energy bending because
he's a hippie
azula does not show that mercy as she
still retains certain ruthless elements
of her personality and she's actually
got some balls so believing that ozai is
beyond
redemption and too large of a threat to
leave alive even without his fire
bending abilities she strikes him down
now she does spare zuko's life after
stripping him of his fire bending powers
but expels him from the fire nation
and makes him live in exile we chose
that ending mostly because it's zuko
and he's awesome nobody wants to see
zuko die
right so things end up pretty much the
same place they do at the start of the
last airbender but the way that we get
to this point is
very very different the avatar rises
from within the fire nation and goes
against her own family to bring about
peace and balance and really
it almost had to end this way as the
avatar has a purpose and destiny to
fulfill and the fire lord was a constant
threat to fulfilling that purpose
as for the other characters in the
animated series most of them especially
those on team avatar like katara
saka and toff would be completely absent
to the narrative and would just go on
living their lives in their respective
hometowns
saka would probably have joined his
father's fleet at some point and so he
may have seen some action that way but i
think the biggest implications of azula
becoming the avatar
is that she may in fact be the last
avatar as there are no new airbenders
being born
and they are next in line for the avatar
upon azula's death
and with aang not growing to adulthood
the line of airbenders
doesn't seem likely to continue and so
that would present a new challenge in
figuring out a way
to rebuild the air nomads so the avatar
spirit can be reincarnated into one of
them when it's time but i think azula
would probably live long enough to make
it past the harmonic convergence that
restore the airbender so i think maybe
that would probably work itself out
i have no real idea but here's my
question should we like do another one
where like azula does what she would
most likely do right she's like she was
always just like i want absolute power
like kill everybody
and conquer the world
because i feel like that's what most
likely would happen
right like like i mean it's cool to see
that she would become like a good guy
right she's like she becomes basically
like anakin skywalker very early on
where like she redeems herself you know
and then like you know becomes like a
good guy but like what if she didn't
though like laid waste to the world like
i feel like we should do that right i
think a really good question here
what if zuko became the avatar i think
that's a question to ask
right like what if that happened what if
zuko ended up becoming the avatar
uh that would be pretty amazing i feel
like we should cover that i feel like
that would be an amazing video so let me
know what you guys think down in the
comment section uh if you guys are new
here to comments explained make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the rob core if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like
i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you